- - Merci Carla.
- - Au revoir.
O On continue la discussion avc
l'l'avocat qui représente Radio-
CaCanada, Me Christian Leblanc.
- - Bonjour Me Leblanc.
- - Bonjour Mme Richer.
- - Quel est le plus grand dangr
dede ce genre de procès tenu das
lele secret absolu? Vous avez
paparlé de la confiance du publc
dadans la justice?
QuQuelque avait soumis au juge?
- - On devrait avoir accès au
dodossier, le plus possible.
DeDeuxièmement, on a soumis un
prprocessus, remettez-nous les
dodocuments, sans révéler
l'l'identité de l'indicateur de
popolice et aider la cour sur si
totout le dossier Dorris à huis
clclos.
- - C'est la question un peu
ététrange.
QuQuand on est un avocat et qu'n
nene sait pas ce que notre vis--
vivis plaide, c'est un peu
dédéconcertant de savoir qu'on e
popose.
- - Tout à fait, et toute notre
sysystème de justice est
coconstruite dans cette... ce
n'n'est pas juste le vocabulair,
plplaide, mais aussi l'accord qi
rereçoit.
SoSous les grands principes, ce
ququ'on a souligné aujourd'hui,n
aiaimerait être un peu plus
paparodique et démontrer à la cr
quque certaines informations, du
momoins objectivement, sans
coconnaître qui contient dans le
dodossier, ce pourrait être
rérévélé.
- - Quel est le plus grand dangr
dede tenir un procès dans ce
sesecret aussi absolu?
- - Pourquoi les médias se battt
dadans la publicité des débats
jujudiciaires?
OnOn a toujours dit que c'est un
prprincipe important.
LaLa cour d'appel l'a dit
égégalement, c'est parce que, pr
avavoir une pleine confiance das
soson système de justice, le
cicitoyen doit voir ce qui se
papasse dans la cour.
SiSi c'est fait de façon cachée,
s's'on ne sait pas ce qui se
papasse, c'est souvent l le débe
lala perte de confiance.
OnOn ne comprend pas pourquouoiy
a a eu un acquittement, on ne
cocomprend pas pourquoi quelqu'n
a a été retrouvé coupable.
MMême chose dans les procédures
ciciviles.
SiSi on voit comment le systèmee
jujustice se déroule, la confiae
esest maintenue.
IlIl faut avoir la plus grande
trtransparence possible.
- - J'entends cet argument de
vovotre part, vous avez dit : ce
popourquoi la réaction était si
foforte de la part du juge en cf
dede la cour supérieure, de la
cocour suprême, les tribunaux st
reredevables.
S'S'on ne sait pas c'est qui le
jujuge, il n'est pas redevable e
ririen.
C'C'est inquiétant.
- - Par exemple, le nom du juge,
etet ce n'est pas pour viser le
jujuge, mais de façon générale,
ququand les citoyens le regarde,
etet qu'un jugement a été rendu
susur la culpabilité.
OnOn ne part de crimes graves,
mamais on ne connaît pas la nate
dudu crime.
MaMais le juge ne peut pas être
coconnu, c'est la même chose por
leles procureurs.
LeLes procureurs de la poursuite
dede cet indicateur sont toujous
sosous le sceau de huis clos.
OnOn ne les connaît pas.
C'C'est une redevance que je
didirais assez de base de que de
coconnaître les gens impliqués.
EnEn même temps, on a dit à la
cocour d'appel qu'il est diffice
dede comprendre, malgré ce qu'on
nene sait pas ce que contient le
dodossier...
- - Évidemment c'est un principe
fofondamental qu'on connaît tou,
lala transparence d'un système
jujudiciaire.
PoPourquoi est-ce que c'est si
imimportant, si sacrée.
IlIl y a un fondement à tout ça.
- - L'histoire nous enseigne que
lolorsque les gens ne savent pas
cece qui se passe dans un lieu
dodonné, on imagine le pire.
- - CK.
- - Le danger avec le système de
jujustice, ce n'est pas juste
cocompte imagine la pire fin du
fifilm, c'est que la confiance
érérode.
SoSon père confiance en notre
sisiège système de justice, on
cocommence à se faire justice s-
mmême.
CeCe n'est pas des grands
prprincipes, c'est comme ça quea
dodoit être connu justement pour
mamaintenir cette confiance.
- - Si jamais, on va spéculer, i
jajamais c'était avalisé par les
trtribunaux supérieurs, encore
plplus supérieure que la cour
d'd'appel, il y a un danger quea
sese répète.
D'D'ailleurs, qu'est-ce qui nous
didit qu'il n'y a pas d'autre
prprocès secret?
- - Ce que la cour nous a révélé
dadans son jugement, ça nous
ininquiète tous.
OnOn verra ça s'est vraiment paé
cocomme ça.
LaLa cour d'appel n'a pas eu de
nunuméro dossier, et aussi l'été
prproduit ce nouveau numéro de
dodossier, il a été occulté.
CÇa été complètement gardé
sesecret.
IlIl y a une différence entre
sasavoir qu'il y a un procès qui
sese déroule à huis clos et ne
mmême pas savoir qu'il y a un
prprocès.